we got this from The Daily Mail National
Guard would be able to use Force against
armed migrants entering the US under new
bill from Navy SEAL veteran Republican
Congressman they going to mention that
House Republicans are pushing a bill
that would authorize the National Guard
to use lethal Force against individuals
with weapons Crossing from Mexico into
the United States they do they do keep
saying that but they also mention the
bill actually says and for other me
other uh uh other issues or whatever
they say in the last year there have
been multiple instances of migrants
Crossing into the US carrying weapons
with some brand brandishing rifles like
an AR-15 as the Biden Administration in
Texas governor Greg Abbot Clash over
border security policies the bill L
trell claims will enable the National
Guard to better protect the US by using
any means necessary to stop armed
migrants look they got photos of these
dudes that's kind of that's kind of wild
I just can't believe that we have to
pass this law what what have we been
doing this whole time it's legit an
invasion I know they're coming armed why
are we not just the headline should just
say Invasion at the border well of
course they won't who who wrote This is
here you go they call him the people
Smuggler oh that sounds like a super
villain name the people Smuggler was
filmed by Texas department of safety
drone on Wednesday near Eagle Pass this
is Wednesday take this photo post it on
Twitter and say Invasion okay spare me
these dudes are coming with rifles and
our our guys aren't even allowed to
defend this country from armed people
wow again why does this have to be a law
I just don't get this I I I mean I'm I'm
glad it is if no has thought that this
is something that's necessary why do we
have a border if we're not trying to
stop people who are entering armed who
are trying to enter illegally wall arms
like again what are we doing here team
well what are we doing s why are these
Governors setting the national guard
down there if they AR aren't I didn't
know they're not allowed to use their
weapons against put out their arms and
be like go
back hold hands and sing a song so I'm
so glad that Rhonda Sanchez and every
all these Governors are sending more and
more National Guard troops because what
are all they can do is just build fences
and say please they're going to link
arms and just be like you cannot cross
they're not allowed to you shall not
pass they're not allowed to retaliate
having been to the Border in Yuma and
seeing how they treat people coming
across the border with like luggage tags
and van rides and plane tickets and
stuff I wouldn't be surprised if they
come with the gun be like do you need
more ammo like where you is everything
okay do you need a case for that rifle
toally crazy hey where didd you get that
did you that that come from here did you
it is interesting to me so there's this
well and then there was another one that
the house passed
yesterday uh saying I I have to remember
uh I should have give this guy credit I
can't remember his name uh basically
it's um Barry Moore from Alabama I think
he proposed this bill that if you if
there's an illegal immigrant who's in
the country and gets convicted of or
admits to driving while intoxicated the
DUI then that's ground that makes them
inadmissible so they couldn't get like a
green card they couldn't get any status
and also it's grounds for deportation
which when I read it it was sort of of
like yes of course because you're here
illegally in the first place already
committed a crime and then you commit
another crime seems like you should
definitely go but the fact that we have
to spell this out cover politics is like
let's just pick one crime that everybody
can sort of gather around like it seems
it also seems reasonable like someone
who commits a crime while in the process
of committing another crime being here
illegally probably I don't want them to
be a citizen probably they are not here
with good intentions yes like it seems
basic and obvious but at the same time
150 Democrats house voted against it
right like it is weird that we have to
say this is a bad idea and in fact there
were congressmen from every border state
you know California New Mexico Arizona
who are Democrats who voted for this so
it makes me wonder like are you seeing
this in your community where there are
people who are here illegally and are
proceeding to you know potentially be
hazards to you know the ilal population
but also the legal residents in this in
in your in your communities weird at a
certain point they just can't deny it
and their constituents are like you our
our places are our homes are ruined this
place is ruined people are leaving the
economy in this town or city is is dying
uh like we see with Eric Adams when he
spoke out but then once he spoke out
wasn't he they tried to meet to him like
a week or two later oh yeah that kind of
disappeared for a while didn't right he
was getting raided by the feds wasn't he
yeah he was jeez man we're at the like
this is the 11th hour dude we got like
can we pull this picture again my
friends he not the only one he's hanging
out in the trees over here bro this is
an
invasion like this guy's got a gun and
and and apparently it's an issue they're
like maybe we should give the National
Guard the ability to like I don't know
fight back when they're being shot at or
something watch him he's a poor Asylum
Seeker he's just trying to you know come
for opportunity hands up don't shoot
it's it's xenophobia it's xenophobic to
question armed Asylum Seekers I'm I'm
actually totally down for saying Asylum
Seekers they're ready to go to war Tim
just like you've been saying he's like
dick deran I'm coming I'm ready I'm here
to I'm here to sign I'm here to sign up
and Fight for Uncle Sam they're like
this guy's got experience no likes to
call them all Seekers even when they're
they're criminal aliens or Smugglers or
whatever and so then you get the right
saying illegal immigrant and I'm telling
people like Criminal Alien is the legal
term for this I'm going back to Asylum
Seeker cuz I'm going to say armed Asylum
Seekers yeah mostly peaceful mostly
peaceful buted possibly peaceful look he
loves the Second Amendment of course
he's an American this Mak peaceful kind
wild and this is I mean I wish I had
listened to a a current
White House briefing today I'm sure if
she saw this was asked about it she'd be
like everything at the border is fine
every don't question this at all like
what point this is for the hardcore
Progressive Democrats I don't know that
anything on this level will convince
them but people who sort of
non-political moderate maybe lean a
little socially left when you see these
pictures at what point are you just like
yes this is incorrect no no no if you
take a closer look and you zoom in you
can actually see there's something on
the back right he's hold holding a small
Anvil he's trying to set up a smithing
shop stop assuming these are criminals
oh it almost looks like a bump stock to
me I the thing is Wy coyote use anvils
all the time for bad things and so I
just that sounds counts as a weapon to
me too Han cl to your point it's like
those people those very same people
you're talking about looking at this and
thinking that they might come to terms
with it the reality of it they're the
ones who looked at the riots and thought
they were just see I think that shifted
I think there are I think there's been
sort of a bleeding effect away because
some of these things are so concrete and
that's why I think a lot of progressive
Outlets a lot of progressive act harp on
January 6 so much because it's a way to
sort of quell the fear like you can't
question anything that's going on
because ultimately look at this very bad
thing theoretically that happened this
one time whereas this is an active
Invasion that's going on constantly and
in fact has been going on for three
years I mean it's what the the official
number is something like we think 6
million IM illegal criminal aliens are
here but when Ronda santz was doing his
uh uh press conference when he was
saying I'm going to send people to the
Border he was like what's the number
like 10 million no one knows how many of
these people are here there's no way of
knowing did you see the Theo Von's tweet
I think it was last weekend he the best
he tweeted
um let's what was it like let's close
get a head count on who's in this MF or
we not doing it justice he had another
Reon too I foret he had a bunch of good
ones he's sois until we can figure out
what's going on you know Charlie as the
uh resident comma expert what's her Take
On the Border wasn't she our borders are
wasn't she supposed to be in charge of
the Border well go back to I think it
was in June 21 when she went to
Guatemala and she held that press
conference and she got real Stern and
said yeah do not come that's right do
not come remember angered AOC and a lot
of other other progressives well I guess
they're not listening to commin well why
would they not listen to KLA I've heard
that she's very influential she's
historic I don't know why they didn't
get the memo why did they make her
borders are does your does your book
know yeah it's kind of this is kind of
uh this was kind of Biden's first uh
attempt to be like all right kamla
you're my buddy vice president you're
going to take one for the team here's
what we did I'm putting you in so I
always wondered if that was him sort of
being like I'm going to give you a bad
job because I don't really like you I
don't want you to be more like
successful than I am and he knew exactly
what he was doing cuz Obama did the same
thing to him Charlie I got to stop you
there though when has anyone ever said
that Biden knows exactly what he's doing
sorry maybe in the first few months of
his first ter okay okay as what vice
president as president well at least his
team knew right because he's had the
same team for decades we've heard
stories I don't got them from Obama I
heard no they're his guys really they're
team Biden is very strong and very
powerful and they are not beholden to
anybody else but their own interests
like they aren't even beholden to the
Biden family at this point it's just
them so why did they want if he was
immediately going to stick her with a
terrible job trying to reign in the
Border not really though if you're a
Democrat why did he select her as VP
like if there's always been a little bit
of tension there was it just that she
would bring him the demographics that he
wanted yeah as I outlined in the book it
was a very political decision he
actually preferred Gretchen Whitmer
because you know she's Midwestern swing
state she campaigned on the idea of
fixing the damn roads you know fed's
Lover he liked that he like they liked
her style of politics and thought she
was a real winner she actually tried to
drop out of the running because you know
the whole the whole process was sort of
overrun by the George Floyd rides and
it's like got very volatile and that's
when everyone sort of started dropping
out you had Amy clobba charge just be
like oh I gotta go former prosecutor
right in Minnesota so like I'm not I'm
not I'm not doing this so you saw more
and more candidates drop out and so he
ended up but he had to pick up you know
he had vowed to pick a woman vice
president and then ultimately it was
clear by you know the senior advisers
that he had to pick a woman of color
during this time of you know racial
tension and he was not doing so good on
racial issues he was going around saying
you know poor kids are just as just as
smart as white kids and you're not
you're not black if you vote for Trump
and so yeah he really had to show that
part of his base that he was serious
about hearing them and getting a woman
of color on the ticket you know you know
what I was thinking it's like it's
really funny how the left says these
Christians are all super hateful and all
that I'm thinking this because I'm like
you know I blame for all of the stuff
happening right now like where we are in
my generation I blame Christian
conservatives and it's because they're
too good of people and they were very
tolerant and accepting to so many really
bad people that they kept acting in good
faith and allowed these far- leftist and
Communists to infiltrate institutions so
I mean that somewhat I'm half joking
right but uh you know 30 40 years ago
you like or 50 60 years ago when you
have a very Christian conservative
Nation evil steps in lies and being good
people they're like well you know I
think we should give these people a fair
chance and now you've got Communists
running over everything and even to this
day the Republican party is still
impotent and won't address these things
I mean Donald Trump gets sued criminally
charged abused mercilessly in these
jurisdictions not a single Republican
jurisdiction is countering I mean maybe
there one or two small ones here there
but where's West Virginia or or Texas
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net